but our common goal must be to help the
British economy off its immigration
dependency
to start investing more in
who are already here
migration is part of our national story
always has been always will be
and the labor party will never diminish
the contribution it makes to our economy
to public services to your businesses
and our communities
but let me tell you
the days when low pay and cheap labor
are part of the British way on growth
must end
this isn't about brexit
all around the world businesses waking
up to the fact we live in a new era for
labor
and while they're adapting
our low growth model is holding us back
it's why we've set out a new deal for
working people that will deliver higher
pay stronger rights and better work
not just for social justice
but also for the new reality on growth
let me give you an example
technology
Britain has fewer industrial robots than
almost every comparable country
we're behind Germany France Spain
Slovenia Slovakia Belgium it's a long
list
and in terms of competition over the
long run
one that borders on disaster
now I know most businesses get this
I've seen for myself how you invest in
your people and their productivity
at valence in Derbyshire
I met the apprentices using their skills
in conjunction with the new technologies
of heat pumps
that technology will continue to adapt
but those apprentices will be at the
Forefront of that change
working today training for the
opportunities of the future